for people for the few people who aren't
familiar with your work how do you
describe what you do
and
what you do online or what you do in
education
well you know the khan academy is most
known for this collection of videos that
i like somewhat famously started making
for my my cousins and then they caught
on people who were not my cousins
started watching them uh but but by the
time it kind of got serious traction and
i had quit my former job in finance to
do this full-time set it up as a
not-for-profit um
our our support has really kind of
allowed us to focus on not only the
videos not only translating the videos
but trying to build our entire
interactive platform so students can get
instruction do practice if they have a
teacher or a parent who can be their
coach they can uh those those folks will
get information on where the students
are at what type what are their
strengths what are their weaknesses and
so the khan academy on one level it's
kind of free tutoring for anybody it's a
not-for-profit everything is free
our mission is a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere
but on a deeper level it's it's uh we've
kind of fallen into this situation and
it kind of speaks to where we are in
history maybe uh where uh
it seems like we're a catalyst for for
helping people think about what a
classroom could be now and um i've never
been a big believer that it should be
virtual only but it feels like now the
virtual can handle certain parts of the
equation it frees up the classroom to do
maybe maybe more interesting things
and what dimensions exactly do you think
virtual education or online
does
arguably better than uh direct
instruction from a classroom teacher
and it's it's it's i i'll
i'll
it's a kind of a careful answer just
because
i think the ideal is you have absolutely
you have both
uh the the real ideal is if you had a
one-on-one with a with a human being uh
but that's not practical uh you know
only
lords and dukes had that hundreds of
years ago what what we're seeing is
students
when they're getting together with
people in a physical environment we
think the best use of that is not the
lecture the one pace fits all lecture
the best use of that time is for the
human beings to actually interact
they're all in the room together and and
so where online's strength is is on
delivering what used to be that lecture
in a way that it's not one pace fits all
anymore so that a student can pause and
repeat at their own time at their own
pace if they're embarrassed by maybe
they're in eighth grade and they forgot
something from fourth grade they don't
have to have the the guts to raise their
hand in class they can just look you
know look at those concepts no one's
going to judge them
if they're ready to move ahead they can
move ahead
software is also really good at kind of
generating exercises grading the
exercises doing a lot of the logistics
that frankly take teachers away from the
actual teaching part of their job
and so what we're saying is in a
traditional classroom
a lot of a teacher's time is spent
giving this lecture to a bunch of
students
oftentimes the classroom is fairly
passive at those moments a lot of the
teachers time is kind of the
administrative work of writing exams
grading exams
and maybe 10 15 of their time is spent
with the actual one-on-one interaction
or small group interaction with students
we're saying if this if
if with technology we can take a lot of
the information delivery we can take a
lot of the logistics a lot of the
problems set creation and grading off of
a teacher's plate 100 of their time
could be the the one-on-one connections
with students and the small group
interactions
i wonder is part of the issue that it's
the sort of the one-to-many kind of
dissemination of information which tends
to be the prevailing model of
instruction
um
that it that is somewhat imperfect
anyway it's sort of like whether you're
doing it in the lecture hall in front of
500 people or if you've got 500 students
online
yeah and you know the irony here and
you're talking to someone who
you know has sat down and made 3 000
videos right sometimes 3 200 now but the
most important part of an education is
not the lecture slash the videos the
most important part of the education is
doing problem solving and interacting
with people and asking questions and
answering other people's questions
and
in traditional classrooms you
that tends to get squeezed out you get a
little bit of it but it gets squeezed
out by the the passive lecture so i
agree with you i think
a lecture is an imperfect thing
it i think gets a little bit better when
you make it on demand when you allow it
to cater to a student's pace and then
technology can also understand what's
working what's not working you can start
to collect data on what's effective
what's not traditional lecturer gets
very little of that data textbooks get
very little of that data now with online
you can have it but i think the the main
focus is
it's a bit of the irony here is that the
technology enables the classroom to
become more interactive more human and
and for me you know there's always there
are always these debates of
is technology good is it is it a
cure-all is it a silver bullet or is it
bad and you know things just gathered us
and for me the question isn't should or
should you not use technology the
question is well what is the ideal
learning experience and you try to
answer that question to me it's a you
know it's it's experience focused on the
student cater to the student's needs
works at the student's pace
and then once you answer that when they
when they when they're around other
human beings they're interacting with
them and and so you say okay that's the
ideal now can we do it and
30 50 100 years ago you couldn't
economically do it you would have to be
quite well-off to have that type of
attention to personalized education
but now i think the answer is we can do
it we can personalize it in a practical
way
the
instructors have not
been brought up obviously in an online
environment the vast majority of them
but they have been brought up with the
concept of differentiated instruction
and i wonder there are some who would
argue well i can adapt my lecture to
students questions to blank stares in
the desks that i'm looking at
is there are there instances where
perhaps in a smaller environment where
maybe a lecture can be equal to or
better than you know a video lecture
style of delivery
yeah absolutely there's certain
circumstances i think if you have a very
small seminar type situation that's
highly interactive then that wins and
actually i would say that's not a
lecture anymore that's actually what we
would want to see
class time used for i think there's also
moments where shared experience is very
powerful
and and i would say that falls more in
the category of inspiring your ted talks
and inspirational speech i think there
is value of having many people in the
room and having that shared that shared
moment but i think for
things that are
intellectually deep things that are hard
for people to get their head around some
person might get it faster than another
person i mean me and you we can watch a
speech
at a high level speech and we'll all get
it but if we're doing calculus we're
doing chemistry you might get it faster
than me i might get it faster than you
it's nearly impossible frankly if you
get even more than 10 or 15 students to
cater to where where every student is
and the only information that a teacher
currently has is trying to read the
blank stares trying to read
how engaged the students are and you
know there have been studies that
the average lecturer is teaching at the
23rd percentile because they're making
sure that no one is is falling behind
and i point out you might say well at
least 23 of the students are are getting
it but no the reality is 77 are bored
and then 22 percent it's going too fast
for us you're only catering to one
percent um and so
i i won't make a blanket statement that
it's always better but
i will i will say that most of the time
when you have human beings together it's
better for them to interact with each
other to ask questions of each other
than for them to
just kind of sit passively and be given
a lecture and a lot of times when people
say well in a live lecture you can ask
questions and i say yeah absolutely
today in a traditional lecture hall
that's maybe five percent of class time
and that's usually only the bravest
people in the class and sometimes even
the question might not be appropriate
for everyone we'd like to see rally
where it's 100 of the class time and
it's not just asking the teacher
questions not just asking the tas
questions but it's also asking your
peers questions where the where the
students themselves get that deeper
experience of explaining things to it to
their to their
colleagues you see
the
they're still being
50 50 split maybe that's not the right
percentage but at least
a part that's online a part that's in
class
have you heard people or or what's your
response to people saying well you know
maybe we can do more of the discussion
part online as well whether it's through
chat rooms and and skyping or or
whatever um
what's the what's the problem or why
should that remain in the classroom or
why not you know ship that into the
online environment as well
i i think we should all experiment on
what what type of social experiences
constructive social experiences you have
online and i think in some domains you
know uh doing skype could be very
valuable for foreign language i mean the
the gold standard has always been
immersion if you can't afford immersion
you skype with somebody who speaks that
language and maybe maybe you could get
interesting results
you know we see on our site we have
we have 60 million students use the site
every month
we want them to interact with each other
we want them to answer their questions
uh with that and and that's incredibly
valuable for someone who maybe does not
have someone else to interact with they
don't have access to a kind of a rich
environment
but it i think the technology would have
to go a very very long way to come close
to what you could get with a very rich
classroom environment that's led by an
inspiring teacher but when i say lead
not being lectured by an inspiring
teacher but really mentored and coached
by an inspiring teacher
given that these are a different set of
skills from teachers from what teachers
have been really brought up in
do you have a vision for how to kind of
get to
the sort of 21st century flipped
classroom instructor that we would need
to do this
yeah and it's an open question i i don't
know 100 i mean it's actually exciting
to be here to at a school that is so
focused on education i i i suspect a lot
of the answer might be for for the the
future teachers to experience it
themselves for them to understand it and
for them to viscerally feel the
difference between being lectured at and
being able to engage with the content
and have conversations with their peers
and discuss it at a deeper level
but i think we're just we're at the very
early stages i mean in my opinion or
it seems like a lot of the adoption's
happening faster than i would have
guessed uh we're being used in twenty
thousand classrooms right now and this
is really just over the last couple of
years and we have two people who engage
directly with classrooms we're a very
small organization so it seems like
there's a hunger out there and a lot of
the teachers we talk to this is kind of
the direction they've always wanted to
be in they've wanted to they got into
the profession because they wanted to
connect with students they wanted to you
know they wanted to be that teacher that
takes that student from you know a
certain attitude to a were they taking
ownership of their life and and they
found it difficult when they have 30
faces that they have to kind of lecture
on right
um
and
one thing that i've heard
as sort of a concern from from teachers
is that there might be a um
well i i maybe i'll put it this way
the concerns have not come just from
teachers but
that online learning often gets sold as
a cost saving you know as something that
okay well we we public education is very
expensive what can we do to save money
do you think it is
a viable way to do education less
expensively
i i kind of i
i don't know um is is a simple answer i
mean i know for my own kids i don't want
them online only and i and i you know
the way i view it if education was
perfect uh we should think about how we
can then you know if we're making a
great car we can then think about how to
streamline the factory or whatever we're
doing but uh you know the reality and
you know there's a million alarmist
articles that come out about all the
reasons why we should worry about
education and so in my mind i would not
try to de-resource the problem i would
try to maybe hold resources constantly
maybe even potentially increase them but
try to get
but try to have better outcomes and so i
view technology as much more of given
whatever resources you have and you know
it's hard to argue that you're ever
putting too much too many resources in
education given whatever resources you
have how do we actually optimize
outcomes
um
you've had a good time doing the videos
that you i mean i don't think you'd do
as
3 000 of them if you didn't like doing
them yes no i i like doing them a lot
yes
do you have any particular favorites
that you
were sort of like
you know you've heard or have you heard
from people who are particularly fond of
a certain video oh you know there's a
bunch i mean well i think one of you
know people ask me like what's the trick
how do you yeah and and i say well
the video that i'm doing i try to
convince myself that's my favorite video
so that you literally have like you know
you hear the energy you hear the
excitement and you can't understate how
important those cues are for the student
if the lecturer themselves
does not care about it the the student
immediately we're very sensitive to that
if you're saying the next step in this
equation i mean who's going to care
about that and so i think it's very
important for the lecturer themselves to
feel excited that they get to do this um
but there's all sorts of topics i i'm a
real big fan of the cosmology videos it
was a reason for me to learn a lot of
cosmology and really understand it and
it's something that always fascinated me
um i i but i get into the finance videos
my old life i was an analyst at an
investment firm and obviously there's a
certain part of me that gets very
passionate about that i i love doing the
history videos i love doing i mean you
know i like i like doing it all
you get some pushback from educators who
are like well he didn't go to education
school he didn't you know do you feel
like
maybe teaching is not as hard as people
uh
make it up to be
no well no i actually isaac i think it's
probably harder than people make it out
to be
and you know depending on what you call
a teacher it's you know
you can determine whether i am one or
whether i'm a content creator i
don't have to or i mean depending on how
you do it you know i don't have 30 live
students that i'm trying to cater to
that i'm you know some of them might
have some problem at home some of them
have some issue some are strug you know
that is a
that is a nuanced and deep and important
role that i am not doing when i just
make a nice resource when i make this
this nice video hopefully it's an
engaging video it gets people excited
about the subject matter and and you
know i want to stress this you know i
recently uh met wendy kopp at dinner the
founder of teach for america
and she was telling me that the single
biggest determinant of the teachers that
they have and they study this very
carefully what are the teachers that are
showing outside outsized gains and most
people think it's going to be content
delivery and there is some correlation
if someone can deliver a good lecture
then their students tend to do well but
the one the thing that that really moves
a dial is a teacher's ability to change
the students mindsets that to make the
students realize that they really have
to take ownership of their learning that
they really have to start thinking about
their futures and and
when she said that i was like well i
need to quote you and i'm quoting her
right now
because that's very consistent what
we're saying instead of five or ten
percent of a teacher's time being that
that that coach that inspiration and
ninety percent being the the content
delivery we want a hundred percent of a
teacher's time being that coach that
inspiration that that that person in the
student's life that can change their
their mindset they can change their
outlook uh that can be that mentor and
that's something i'll never be able to
do as a video creator
and you need a live human being for
do you think there's much of a stretch
between
standing in front of a group of 25
students and doing an exercise at the
board versus doing an exercise in a
youtube video that's going to be seen at
home
you know we've been we're and we're
constantly looking for folks to make
more and more videos and obviously
there's some incredible teachers out
there many many incredible teachers but
we found that um
there's a certain nervousness once you
record yourself and you put it out there
for the world to see and comment on um
and so yes there there is a difference
when you i mean i actually don't think
about it when i make a video i kind of
just imagine my cousin's listening and i
think it just makes it more intimate and
warm hopefully but uh we have seen folks
who are i think amazing teachers in the
in physical form but when they know
they're being recorded uh they tend to
get a little nervous
and i think teachers are
accustomed to making relationships or
forming relationships with students that
they have right in front of them and
there's
this uncertainty around well how am i
relating to how are relating how are
students relating to me
when they see me on their computer
and is that obviously you started with
your cousin so i don't know if you ever
sort of went through that period of
uncertainty yeah no i go through that
period of uncertainty every time i
upload a video and and this is what's
exciting these days is i can upload a
video
now and within an hour i'll get 50
comments from kids all of all ages i
shouldn't say just kids all over the
world and uh it matters to me i mean it
really helps me if a few say wow that
really helped that was exactly what i
needed i've gotten through that concept
now and so in that way i get much more
direct feedback you know i've i've done
i've never been a a professional teacher
but i've done some teaching in college
and you know i used to give a lecture or
teach a class and the day would go but
no feedback i'd get i'd get insecure
and and that would happen and maybe at
the end of the term you might get one or
two students if you know if you're lucky
who might say oh that was really helpful
you know thank you um but you don't get
that direct feedback as as often and and
you know in online you get that feedback
for better or worse i mean sometimes the
feedback can be harsh but once again
that that can only make you better
would you expect every instructor to
produce their own content or do you
think that there could be just a
standardized repository that the
teachers would draw from i i think both
i mean i'd like to see a world where
every uh instructor if they're not happy
with what they're seeing out in the
world that they are creating their own
if they hey i could do better than that
i you know that that person's not
covering this nuance or this angle let
let me do something uh with that said i
i can't imagine over time the the
content delivery you know just as every
teacher is not writing their own
textbook that you kind of start to
settle on it becomes reasonably resource
intensive you know now we can actually
use data and analytics to figure out
which of the the the videos and once
again i think the videos are much in
some ways they're analogous to the text
in a textbook but we can start to
measure how effective is it how engaging
is it and uh i could you know in five or
ten years
we won't need thousands of
explanations of factoring a polynomial
we could have a handful that have proven
themselves to to really engage students
and and uh resonate with them i have one
last question
okay
um
which is the the level of of work that
this type of education requires as
opposed to what teachers are accustomed
to doing now
what i've heard from one instructor who
does sort of a hybrid kind of you know
does a little bit of both he's like well
this the classes that have an online
component you really have to develop all
those online pieces in advance and then
you still have all of the work of the
you know regular interaction with
students
in short it sounds like it is more work
it may be worth it but do you think that
it is more work and perhaps worth it or
what's your view on that
what we're seeing is yeah i think today
in most schools especially i would say
public schools
where a teacher wants to do something in
this direction
it is more work for them today because
to some degree they have to serve two
masters they have to serve the
traditional master of this is the state
curriculum you have to do this in this
week but the same time they want to have
the flexibility and
and allow the students to work at their
own pace and cater to the students so it
is more work for them today
it's less work than if they wanted to do
a a student-centered curriculum 10 years
ago without any technology
with that said the direction that
everything seems to be going in is that
the tools are getting better you know
khan academy itself is nowhere near
being a perfect tool
we have a list of 200 things that we
need to fix about it make it easier for
teachers to use make it easier for them
to plan their curriculum
we have to add a lot more content so
that people don't have to go and fill in
the gaps in other places there's other
people making more and more tools so i
suspect as the tools get better as uh as
as kind of the the curriculum becomes
clearer i think this adoption of the
common core is actually a huge
opportunity
because states have adopted it it hasn't
kind of fully gone into implementation
yet
i think all of these things are kind of
converged the technology is going to
become more usable and more accessible
right now teachers have to struggle with
trying to get the laptop cart for their
class at the right period hopefully a
lot of those things are going to solve
themselves over the next four or five
years so yes it's i would say it's
harder today but the teachers think it's
worth it uh but i would suspect five ten
years from now it might be easier than a
traditional model okay
well thanks i should probably wrap up
now i could ask you lots more questions
oh no no no great great yeah that's
great questions i appreciate it